never forget like before we took one
vote uh I won't say who but but one of
the leaders of this of this 20 stood up
and McCarthy asked him like what it what
else do you guys want like let's just
settle this before we go out there and
look like fools like what what else can
we do for you
and he's like and he just couldn't
answer it in front of everyone that was
a really frustrating moment so that's
that's actually where all the animosity
came from because it felt like it was
just for show
all right I'm Dave Rubin and yes this is
a different set because we are in the
swamp that's right we are in Washington
DC and joining me across the table is a
former Navy SEAL and now a U.S
congressman representing Texas's second
district Dan Crenshaw welcome back to
the Reuben report great to be here in
this small bunker I know here in
Washington DC this is a little smaller
out here you know it's uh it's compact
welcome glad you're out here I am glad
to be here you just got in from Texas
like seven minutes ago yeah yeah yeah
do you need a moment I'm waiting for the
Sudafed to kick in that's what I'm
waiting for if I'm being particularly
honest
seven that you're you're yeah I must be
I don't know I think it's just allergies
got got into a sign you know you know
how it is I'm fine we'll work through it
I guess we shall see so I said to you
right but when you walk you just walked
in two seconds ago but I said you're
right when you walk in that we we
offered I told uh Republicans and
Democrats alike about 20 on each side
that I'm in DC for three days I will
interview anyone
and I will treat everyone with respect
and all that stuff basically every
Republican said Yes except Mitch
McConnell who has a he felon I think he
heard his leg or hip I think he might be
in the hospital at the moment so I'll
accept that one uh and not one Democrat
even responded we didn't even get no's
we got just nothing yeah does that kind
of sum up what's going on here in DC
these days
yeah yeah it kind of does there's let's
unpack that a lot one I think it's
political malfeasance on their part yeah
I see a lot more Republicans go on
left-wing shows I I like doing I've done
it a lot yeah
um you know you and frankly it's good
for your it's good for if you only care
about catering to your own base it's
actually still good for that because
your base still loves watching you say
you know go toe-to-toe with somebody who
disagrees with you right right and it's
it's fun it's intellectually stimulating
there's a lot of other reasons I like
doing it and but most I mean most
importantly you know I always say like
politics fighting in politics what is
fighting in politics fighting in
politics means persuading others that's
the actual that's the metric by which
you fight a lot of people think
otherwise right it's just yelling and
screaming and picketing and doing all
that and maybe you know dying on dying
on Hills that you knew you were going to
die on that's not fighting that's
fighting for your base's attention
there's a certain kind of fight but
you're not really fighting for them and
so fighting means persuading and the
best way to persuade is to get your
point across in a reasonable manner on a
show where where you know the audience
generally disagrees with you so yeah I
don't get it so I think it's political
malfeasance but to your question about
is it a broader indicator
um of what goes on here on the hill yeah
yeah to an extent I mean you know I'll
give you an example we're in ENC Energy
and Commerce Committee we're marking up
some bills and some of these are kind of
obviously you know not things Democrats
will vote for but some of them are not
so obvious so here's one like scheduling
fentanyl analogs as a schedule one drug
so that should be pretty plain and
simple like by the way this is like
stuff that basically acts like vegetable
or something yeah an analog means it's
been it's kind of been chemically
altered by this exact yeah exact same
basic makeup and an outcome I'm probably
getting that somewhat scientifically
wrong bad stuff but legally speaking
like you need to do it so we can go
after these dealers in a cohesive way
which is a way that's not happening
right now prosecutors have a really hard
time
um uh Prosecuting even not just not even
just fentanyl but like fentanyl analog
something slightly different that does
the exact same thing
um I mean marijuana is a schedule one
drug we can debate that separately but
like the point is is this shouldn't be
that controversial to make fentanyl a
schedule on drug by the way it's already
temporarily a schedule one drug it it
expires soon I want to get too much into
this particular
um issue but but the point is it's
really not that controversial and
Fentanyl is hurting everyone across the
country
and they all I think two Democrats maybe
voted with us on that
um you know the things that should be
bipartisan that there really shouldn't
be that controversial they find reasons
to make them controversial now I think
when we were in the minority we might
have done the same thing every once in a
while like you know nitpick some silly
things but I would say only once in a
while I I think it happens a lot more
um with Democrats and it certainly
happens a lot more in the house
uh the reason being is that if you're
you know if you're a politician you're
sitting in the minority
maybe you do kind of like a policy but
you also don't really want to take heat
from back home for voting for it from
your own base because you gotta your
first election is always your primary
you know it's going to pass I just vote
no the the no vote is the easiest vote
in the world
um and a lot of people just vote no one
just literally everything right is it
sometimes not just that they're worried
about the base but they're worried about
the radicals that are here like that
that's going to cause more of a headache
than say their voter who might be a
little more left than they are
um well I don't know what do you mean by
radicals here well meaning like let's
say the the squad
more of a headache for them than their
own base that might just be like ah yeah
we'll let it slide on this issue well
same thing so same thing so so yeah I
mean they might be afraid of somebody in
the squad tweets something which Riles
up their basic.com it's that's the
dynamic yeah so but it's kind of the
same thing yeah so let's do a whole
bunch of stuff all right all right let's
go uh well first how about we do start
with this because I think a really
interesting moment that we had that you
probably don't even know about is I
think the first time maybe the second
time we met was at a turning point USA
event during the first Trump impeachment
so this was right before Christmas I
guess this is like 2018 or something and
I'm sure you remember the moment where
you actually brought up your card what
it was the card that that you said no on
impeachment is that what it was yeah so
you actually brought that up on stage to
Trump in the middle of his speech he
called you on and you brought up the
card and you signed it for him that that
night was the first night that I ever
met Trump in person and that was
basically when I started saying I could
support this guy because you supported
him and I was like I like Crenshaw I
like then having met Trump I was like I
like him personally they put some of the
pieces together
um that feels like a long long time ago
doesn't it just the way the way the
world in 2018 felt compared to 2023
putting aside the specifics yeah yeah
massively massively different I've only
been in politics four years so I'm in my
fifth year third term
fifth year I guess if you count running
for running for congress for about a
year you could I could say it's five
years in politics but that's that's not
very long how many years does that age
you uh I don't know I just turned 39.
so I don't feel like I've been aged but
um but you know at least I won't admit
it but I will say yeah the the um the
atmosphere is very different you know
the 2018 primaries were very different
than 2022 primaries uh 2020 primaries
were non-existent at least for me I
didn't even have a contender yeah and
now now there's there's nobody that runs
without a primary Contender and can run
like way to the right or way to the left
so politics has gotten way more extreme
um on both sides and um it's gotten
vicious and angrier and it is it is a
wildly different time
um
yeah everybody
I do miss those days
2018 or the good old days I mean that's
kind of yeah I mean covet obviously
escalated a lot of things it did just
but just the general sense I mean I know
you well enough like you really do want
to sit down with some of these other
people and do you when you see them like
when you see some of the progressives in
Congress when you're at the Capitol does
anyone chat with you like are they
willing to talk even on the DL or is it
just there's nothing there yeah yeah no
that there is but um you know the
frustration comes from it's it's very
hard to get them to act but don't but
you know I do want people to realize
there's actually a lot more good faith
conversations and attempts than people
might realize
doesn't always end up or we'd like it to
it rarely ends up where we'd like it to
um but you know
I mean well let me let me draw your
attention back to um uh Kevin McCarthy
um uh speakership yeah not because I
want to talk about that drama it's on
the list it's on the list damn it but
because no but actually what I wanted to
bring up was the the hilarious bad lip
reading that came from that oh I saw it
I saw it and how often did you see bad
lip reading between like hardcore
Freedom caucus members and AOC they talk
to each other quite a bit you know and
like people do talk to each other right
there there is some yelling and
screaming uh publicly but like I've
actually I've gotten completely out of
the habit of going after anyone
individually in the house uh sign it up
for grabs like you know Bernie Sanders
all day long President Biden that's yeah
totally totally free-for-all but but I
tried not to even go after anyone in the
house unless absolutely necessary
because you do have to see them every
day and there there might be something
you work on I mean so like I'm trying to
get psychedelic treatment for veterans
and Military uh AOC is a big proponent
of that also we're neighbors now we
literally our offices we just got moved
this year we are right next to each
other
we're right next to each other so so we
just um yeah just I prefer a world where
we actually try to figure some things
out I'm trying to get a bunch of
Democrats on my cartel bills right now I
mean that's not out of the question yet
okay and I've not made it partisan I
want I want Democrats to agree with me
that we have to go after the cartels in
Mexico so I mean there's room there's it
can happen I still have some Faith okay
so since it sounds like you're extending
a hand to AOC just on my show this
morning that we just finished an hour
ago I played a clip of her during you
know giving her her speech during the
parental rights and education bill that
just got passed and she's screaming how
this is fascism that if parents know
these things that this is fascism and
all the bill is I ex as I I basically
read all the bullet points it's just so
that parents know what's being done
their reaction to this one is so crazy
so what do you do with that then so you
wanna you wanna put the hand out there
you want to maybe work with her on
things that make sense okay so I got
the way it works up here is like we just
ignore it hey William co-sponsor this
yeah sure great right um so which is
which is healthy actually because like
what's what's interesting is I do think
a lot of the emotion leaves the room
um when when behind closed doors
um and that's a good thing frankly like
like I haven't actually specifically
talked to her about the psychedelics but
I just know that she's promoted
something similar
um like this this is one of those weird
things where it's like me Matt Gates and
AOC like all on the same page about
something right um you know I'm just
it's just an example but you know my
comments about X Y and Z don't
necessarily need to affect her opinion
on this bill and her comments on X Y and
Z don't necessarily need to affect my
opinion on on this bill because well
it's about a greater good it's about
getting military people treatment that
they need so so it it can still happen
right like um I it really can and
sometimes I mean but what do you do
about the over the top writer because I
don't hear that from you obviously I'm
more in line with your politics but like
I like she knows it's not fascism but
but then you say that it gets clipped
everywhere it goes around and then and
then that just becomes the mainstream
thought on this thing we gotta fight
back on that issue like I can fight back
on that issue against her I'm just
saying
um I'm trying to make people feel
somewhat better about DC yeah that's all
I'm trying to do I'm just saying we can
fight like hell on that like she's
totally lying and totally wrong and I
would say it publicly
um it's it's completely disingenuous
it's complete grandstanding it's it's
it's in all the Democrats have been
saying it by the way they're all using
the same line
um like this kind of sky is falling
rhetoric I'm just saying we can fight
about that and probably still do a bill
on something else that we agree on right
it can't happen and it should happen
like if if you let your entire life and
entire career and certainly Washington
politics be driven completely by emotion
uh we'll definitely never get anything
done because it largely is already
driven too much by emotion right it's
interesting because the rhetoric is so
out of whack with what most people think
of the country even you know because
most of what they're running on to me
seems like radical anti-American radical
anti-American ideas and all of the woke
stuff and then the other day Hakeem
Jeffries was suddenly talking about
American exceptionalism and it's like
well pick one guys but then I kind of
think that's almost baked in it's like
we say every extreme thing so people
have no freaking clue what's going on
here and then you get left holding the
hat like hey I'm trying to the
intellectually honest and consistent
people yeah I do get left hold the Hat a
lot of times
um because sometimes my own side wants
me to like really go extreme and I'm
like that's not really intellectually
honest
what you know whatever the whatever the
example is and so I tend to look for
people on the other side who also share
that same kind of intellectual honesty
and consistency who kind of maintain
some sort of consistent equilibrium
aoc's not one of those people like it
just to be clear I'm just I just I
didn't mean to make it about her I just
she says these things and I'm like man I
know you don't believe this lady you're
I would say she's LARPing she's live
yeah yeah it's true it's just true I
mean Hakeem Jeffrey said the same stuff
on the parent on the parents Bill of
Rights yeah thing he was saying the same
things like book burning they want to
stop teaching the Holocaust we played
this one what are you talking about like
it's it's complete it's completely
bananas I I do
not that being said as just a Republican
strategist putting that hat on I like it
when they do that because it's so easy
to debunk you know it was like the
Georgia election law the Texas election
laws those were so easy to debunk they
looked ridiculous and they did lose
those battles
um so it does drive us crazy when they
do that but we do also have to take a
step back think about it unemotionally
and think this is an opportunity right
because it's so easy to fact check them
right
um they've gone they've miscalculated
they've gone too far uh it's an
opportunity for us to win over those
Independents who are like you know I I
don't like that they lied to me I
believed it for a second but then you
showed me this and I read it and it's
not like that and that's an opportunity
for us so I can tell you really want to
talk about the McCarthy fight for at
least 17 minutes
let's do Let's do let's do literally two
minutes on it so you were basically in
McCarthy's Camp then it was sort of
getting nasty for a couple days the
media loved it because Republicans were
fighting with Republicans okay fine are
you happy in the end result in that it
does seem to me that the Republican are
standing up a little bit more and maybe
the fight did actually give it some
teeth or do you think it was going to
end up that way either way it was going
to end up that way either way I mean
what what what really bugs me about that
whole week was that nothing really
changed from day one to day five or
whatever it was
as far as the substance of the so-called
demands right this rules package we
passed it had already been agreed to and
it was a pretty uncontroversial rules
package everybody liked it
um so what about these concessions that
they got they're all secret the whole
thing yeah yeah although those are
personal concessions that we don't quite
understand or know about that's that's
another fun meaning that behind closed
doors McCarthy was like okay I'll Matt
Gates I'll offer you this or something
into that and I can't talk specifics
because I don't really know exactly but
that's but but the point is is the
actual written down rules the supposedly
again I think so there was a narrative
out there they were fighting for this
like more transparent better more
Republican more democratic rules package
but it was already agreed to it was this
exact same from from start to finish the
effect itself did not it didn't change
well there was one tiny change which is
like the motion of AK change from five
votes to one vote which is like nothing
so that's something that's splitting
hairs at that point
um so that's what was frustrating it was
it was frustrating too because I mean um
you know I'll never forget like before
we took one vote
uh I won't say who but but one of their
kind of leaders of this of this 20 stood
up and McCarthy asked him like what it
what else do you guys want like let's
just settle this before we go out there
and look like fools like what what else
can we do for you
and he's like hey you just couldn't
answer it in front of everyone that was
a really frustrating moment so that's
that's actually where all the animosity
came from because it felt like it was
just for show so that's interesting so
that's the rights version of what we
were talking about before with the left
right like just the show version of all
yeah it was just it was just frustrating
and it wasn't cleared uh to those of us
who were supporting him why
again I can negotiate with somebody if
you're like no I really want this rule
to change and I'm like well let's meet I
can I can figure that I can wrap my head
around that but that just wasn't what
was happening
um and I I think that's where the
animosity came from because I'd go
around asking some of them like what
what else like I'll go I'll go talk to
them what do you want me to talk to them
about like let's just let's just get
through this and I wouldn't get answers
and that that was really frustrating
that's why I think the heat got turned
up so much but I think we're but I also
think we're definitely past it now
Washington tends to be like that which
frankly apparently right next to each
other yeah which is but it's a good
thing it's you got to get over stuff
right you really do so if you have a
bathroom in your office or you have to
share a bathroom with these people too
no no uh we have a bathroom there's one
in the hallway yeah yeah yeah they're
there yeah every every member uh office
has a bathroom no shower but a bathroom
okay all right so you're not going to
share a bathroom I assume they would be
genderless
that's true what do you make up of the
general sense that and I definitely feel
this as you know I left Cali and I'm in
Florida now that the red States and blue
States The Divide right now is so wide
that it can only get wider at least 10
rarely do you think that's a fair
assessment and and are you okay with it
if if it's a fair assessment no I'm not
okay with it it's bad for the country
um we need we need honest balance in the
country and uh you need a healthy
liberal side and a healthy conservative
side you know liberals have their place
right there they point out problems with
the hierarchies and the institutions
that are set up you know I think their
Solutions are almost always wrong that's
where you need conservatives right I
think conservative governing philosophy
is by far the best one and the
healthiest one but you got to take cues
from from people and that's so the
Liberals play a role like that balance
is actually really important and that
balance is way out of whack and and and
we got problems in the Republican party
for sure I I think populism is bad
mostly because it so closely resembles
liberalism in my opinion but meaning
that they'll use government to get
whatever it is that yeah it is
untethered from principle it's generally
telling people what they want to hear
that's how I Define populism and that's
certainly how I observe it in practice
um so this would be like where you you
and Tucker definitely see that
differently yeah yeah I'm not really
sure what he's for in many cases um I
mean you know he hates me because I
think we should defend America and and
stand up to Russia like that that's why
that's why he doesn't like me I'm not
sure what else we disagree on he's
probably is more willing to use the
powers of government in a very
non-conservative way on certain things I
don't want to put words in his mouth
we'd have to be really specific on the
issue but just in general when you look
at populism here's an example I mean I
remember this is the 2020 election
we were talking about free paychecks you
know two thousand dollar checks to
everyone
um Universal paychecks and I remember
the far right being like you got to do
this this is what needs to be done this
is you know and it was I was like well
why not three thousand why not four
thousand the entire point of being a
conservative is to have some kind of
tethered principle some anchoring there
that's to be it's called limiting
principles
um so that's populism right because I'm
like you know is it going to be popular
to give everyone a two thousand dollar
Check Yes does that make it the right
thing no like so so that's what I mean
by that and liberalism just it just is
the is the political mechanism for that
kind of mentality but do you really
speak any are they aware of the Liberals
though I mean I see I see socialists
mostly you probably saw that incredible
moment on Real Time a couple weeks ago
when Bill basically said to Bernie
what's the difference between equity and
equality and he literally said he didn't
know I mean that should have that was
interesting because it's like he's never
thought of it yeah because we we have
that conversation in our circles quite a
bit like you know we nitpick at their
philosophy we really really try to
understand their psychology and
philosophy and they never try to
understand conservatives like they they
just they actually default to
demonization it's actually appalling but
also it's a huge Advantage for us
because I always know what they're gonna
say I always know how they're going to
make their point and that was such a
good example of like Bernie's never even
really thought of that that that that
it's an important difference you know
and Bill eventually got him to kind of
say what we would want him to say you
know it's like about how come work he
was like yeah you fool He's just never
thought of it yeah which was which was
crazy so it's it's proof that they're
driven by like but that the left is
driven by populism and kind of what
feels good at the moment sort of
mentality right this this kind of
outsized like pathological sense of
compassion like you can have too much
compassion right that will that will I
don't know to kind of just screw up your
entire framing of a problem and then how
you approach you've read some Jordan
Peterson yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
mutual friend you've done many things
yeah so wait I want to back up to go to
Russia for just a sec so because I think
we have a little bit of a difference
opinion as a general rule I believe in
strength to stop your enemies and I
believe in deterrence and all of those
things there's something that feels
different to me about this thing because
we're so screwed up internally right now
like because of inflation and all of the
craziness of the last couple of years
that we're giving all of this money and
that people are just like yes give them
four more tanks and three more planes
and pay for this and it's like we know
that's not going to end it and he has
nukes so it's not so I think I probably
agree with you on like the the blue sky
like policy what should foreign policy
look like
I just think we have a bunch of
incompetent buffoons running this and
and that changes my equation a little
bit maybe
um you can always find a reason you know
to to want to solve this problem instead
of that problem but they're not mutually
exclusive you know
um giving money to Ukraine for weapons
says it has zero inflationary effect uh
for one
um I think you'd have a much higher
inflationary effect if you looked at the
counter factual so if we're going to say
we should never support Ukraine you do
have to operate with a counterfactual in
mind and that counter factual is this we
never okay fine we never gave him
anything they were never our Ally we
don't care if Russia takes them over for
all we care you know it doesn't concern
us at all
but we have to say that because because
that is the the obvious counterfactual
so so that means Russia takes over right
that means we don't do anything we never
gave him javelins we never gave him
Stingers we never gave them the weapons
that helped them fend the Russians off
and in the Battle of Kiev and we never
trained them for the last few years
right we never did any of that
um Russia would win and also their
military would be intact so you'd have
an intact Russian military with a with a
with a with now an emboldened Putin
because now the population's way behind
them they weren't really behind they're
not really behind them now because he's
not winning and they don't like being
conscripted into his army but in the
counterfactual they're winning they
haven't lost him so much and now they're
on the borders of Poland Slovakia
Hungary Romania all NATO countries with
an imperialistic mindset I mean Putin's
talked many times about you know freeing
Russian ethnic Russians throughout
Europe
um Estonia has a lot of those Latvia has
a lot of those NATO countries so there's
there's I I think we have to take Putin
at his word right we we rarely do for
some reason I mean he says he's going to
do things we should accept his word and
acknowledge that he's going to do it you
know and this he he he's always he's
always played war games that are
offensive in nature they're never
defensive like this idea that he's been
afraid of NATO and he has to like create
a buffer zone that's complete nonsense
they never practice defending Russia
because they know they don't need to
it's not a reasonable concern also NATO
is just not not designed that way and he
knows that he's not a stupid man he's a
very rational guy but he's rational
within a Russian context okay so he's
not we westerners look at what's
happening they're like this is
completely irrational Yeah by our
standards because we operate in this
sort of rules-based order we believe in
sort of Goodwill and Partnerships that's
not how he thinks he lives in like the
18th century he does see himself he's
talked about this he sees himself as the
sort of second coming of the czars so he
sees himself as an imperialist and he
believes in strength like he respects
you because you're strong and if you're
not strong he believes it's his right to
take things from you which is how he
sees Ukraine he doesn't see sees them as
sub-human and so for less than 10
percent of our defense budget which is
which is the amount of money we're
talking about we can just make that
scenario not happen that's a pretty good
deal so damn good investment so we just
completely decimated the Russian
military now is it purely competent well
look Biden's not actually doing every
every little bit of this thank God
because he is incompetent and he was
incompetent with Afghanistan at a
massive weight and listened to his
military
in this case he is listening to his
military now he's still not he's still
making mistakes in the sense that you
know he should have done more quicker
and ended this you do have to escalate
to de-escalate and then call for a
resolution that's that's the strategy
here that should be what the President
should be saying but he's not really
saying much and that's the problem and I
think that's why people like you were
like I don't think you're competent's in
this so I get that right because it's
also that every week we play a clip of
him or Lincoln or one of these guys
saying well they shouldn't negotiate and
they and we should just continue and
it's like well yeah I just don't think
you know right before the election was
it right before the election I think
Mitch McConnell said that the Ukraine
war is number one on Republican voters
minds and it was like I I played that
clip on my show and literally the amount
of email I got of people being like it's
not in my time 20 not to say what you
just said is not important yeah but
people when they're like I can't order a
freaking couch because it now takes six
months they're like yeah it it annoys
people I get that and certainly that's
not our most important thing in the
world but it is important I
I don't like being in the business of
overstating it either which is I think
what you're referring to
so what does the end look like then like
what because I to me it's just like
we're just going to keep doing this like
every couple weeks we'll be like all
right there's more money couple more
tanks the only defense of those kind of
comments is you got to remember who's
listening it's not just your voters it's
the Russians and so that's actually
that's that's that's part of strategic
deterrence make them think we'll just
never stop because that that has to
factor into his calculations as well
um now what but I'm since I'm not at the
top levels of government I'm a little
bit more free to say what should happen
and it's kind of what I just said I
think you should escalate to de-escalate
um and you do have to force some kind of
resolution that just stabilizes the
situation it's not it's not ultimately
important to Americans that like a few
miles of Ukrainian territory is impeded
upon
um at least to the voters but you do
have to set up permanent deterrence in
this case
um and you actually should think it's
pretty important that Ukraine doesn't
get taken over by Russia
um there's been there's a lot of
narrative on our own side that it's just
this Backwater country that doesn't
matter that that's economically speaking
just totally false
um you know I'll give you some exam I
mean it is the Bread Basket of the world
for a reason
um they're still doing those exports so
there's a reason like things haven't
completely gone to Hell yet
um I think it produces most of the
world's neon which is used for
semiconductors so that that's in every
single thing every little part of your
life is is based there uh quite a bit of
our steel or at least a pig iron ore
comes from Ukraine so there's
there's a lot of resources there that
there's a reason Putin wants it again
he's rational by Russian standards
there's a reason he wants this
particular area if we're going to
control that much
um is is is not in America's interest
now is it worth us fighting a nuclear
war over no it didn't say that either
but we're not and we're not even close
to that we've not lost a single American
we don't plan to lose a single American
we've just written a check for less than
10 of our defense like I mean that's so
so it was just speaking of cost benefit
I think there's massive benefits here
with with very little cost you also have
to look at how China looks at this yeah
so when you saw him with G last week
like does that concern you that somehow
now we've just sort of like forged this
new alliance it was already forged I
mean I mean remember they were meeting
right before Putin invaded I mean they
were they were planning this together
she encourages this
um because he wants to see what the West
reaction is right so so she is doing his
own kind of red cell observation you
know what I mean by Red Cell okay so red
cells just like a military determine we
do kind of a
maybe right cell is not even the right
term in this case now I've over
complicated the conversation but in any
case it's it's it's she gets to she gets
to observe a scenario right where where
there's an unjust Invasion and he gets
to observe what the West's reaction is
okay because he wants to obey Taiwan
obviously
and he wants to know how long the West
will stay together how much we're
willing to invest he wants to know these
things and so of course he's going to
encourage it it's in his interest that
that Putin is successful and that we
quit because of that that get that in in
effect green lights his invasion of
Taiwan that's what he's looking for
now you've you really don't want Taiwan
to be taken over by the Chinese right
just just simply for the semiconductor
problem you also don't want to go to war
over it so the best method here is is
prevention
um that's a that's a whole other
conversation about what we could do
better to prevent that I jumped
completely from the the red blue thing
into the into Ukraine but
what do we do to mitigate that if we
want to say the United States and we're
watching these states I mean when I
would go back to Cali now I'm like man
this place has nothing to do with
anything that I believe in or want to be
part of it seems ridiculous to me
well I don't know maybe I'll go back to
what I said earlier you got to be
persuasive right we've got to convince
like moderate liberals and independents
that conservatism is just a simply A
Better Way Forward
um you know there's a tendency in
American politics to look to the worst
of the other side and they're like you
know so they'll pick the person on the
other side they hate the most and be
like this is why I can't be with you
guys
and because we could because we and it's
because we so rarely talk about our
principles
um I think that's a problem that's why I
I tend to try to talk in philosophical
terms to get people like let's start
from the foundation here let me explain
to you how I get to this policy that you
think is just the devil
um you know when it's not and you know
let's go from there I mean
I like this situation are your offices
literally like you share a wall with AOC
is it that next door yeah like literally
you share a wall yeah I think this my
office probably stares a wall with her
staff but yeah but but yes but it is yes
I like that maybe like if anyone can do
it it's probably you like bring her to
something ballpark saying maybe it's
hard to say you know
I don't know I know you'll try yeah
yeah well like I said I'll at least try
on like this one issue that I know she
already agrees with right but you're not
going to convince people who are that
far left just to be clear like you know
my my when I say I'm talking to
Democrats about my car fascism like
you're pretty good about yeah how about
that all right one more for you then uh
obviously the big thing on on the
Republican side is the Trump DeSantis
thing that seems to be happening
DeSantis has not announced but it all
seems like it's going in that direction
I voted for Trump I like Trump I love
what's happening in Florida like I'm
trying to do it as honestly as possible
and I think we need a shift in
Generations like there's a whole series
of things what do you make of this and
how worried are you that this just like
implodes the whole thing and we get Joe
Biden yeah another 30 years I'm very
worried uh that it implodes and that
there's massive division in the party
um I'm staying out of it I mean I'm not
going to comment one way or the other
who I like better yeah because
um everybody's just a little angry bit
upset at each other and there's there's
really no benefit
um to doing so it's early it's early too
so Santa's will he will he announce you
I'm pretty sure he will uh but he hasn't
um there's only a handful that I have
and so we'll we'll let this play out but
I'm absolutely worried for our party
um and and you know the how these
divisions manifest and more importantly
what it means for our potential for
victory uh in 2024. so we need to get it
together Rachel I can't let you leave on
a worried comment because my policy
around here is I gotta get something
positive let's talk about going to work
let's talk about going to war with the
cartels fine there we go finish yeah
yeah that's something that'll bring us
all together I think every uh well it
brings Republicans together I'm trying
to make it bring Democrats together so
you know I've recently uh was threatened
by the president of Mexico oh right and
he's getting he's gonna yeah yeah he's
gonna he's gonna come campaign against
me I thought that was mildly hilarious
it actually shows how bad this situation
really is so you know this is our number
one tactical security threat we have
strategic security threats Russia China
those are strategic security threats
long-term security threats as far as you
know keeping chaos out of the world
because that affects Americans but this
this is a this is a near term tactical
major security threat right on our
border these cartels are small armies
they can battle the Mexican Army they've
bought off much of Mexican government uh
you know what my reaction to amlo saying
what he said to me was wow tell me your
tell me you're bought off by the cartels
without telling me you're bought off by
the cartels I mean because I never came
after him he just uh you know I I go
after the cartels I don't go after
Democrats on this either because I'm
trying to get them on this bill
um that would simply give Biden the
authorization for military force it
doesn't mean you roll tanks in tomorrow
it just means you have authorization
ideally we do that with Mexico just like
we've done in many other operations
around the world so I think this is a
this is this is this is my major focus
is is the cartels in Mexico the fentanyl
they're producing and shipping across
our border poisoning murdering Americans
every single day I'll make you a deal I
will focus on that a little more so you
get a little juice behind you and you
will walk over to aoc's office within
the next couple weeks and tell her to
respond to my email okay all right can
you please respond to Dave's email he's
very nice guy thanks Dave if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell